bu
[Alkış]
1980ler dünyanın ilk internet ha bu
şekilde gözüküyor birbirine zar zor
bağlı sadece birkaç tane bilgisayardan
ibaret
Şimdi ise Nerede olursanız olun benim
konuşmamı canlı bir şekilde
izleyebiliyorsunuz ister okulda olun
ister bu tür konuşmaları en çok
izlendiği yerde nerede tuvaletiniz de
peki şimdi bankacılık sistemine
baktığımızda ne görüyoruz Tüm işlemleri
yöneten bir grup Merkezi şirket bu
firmalara paramız ve işlemlerimiz için
güvenmek dışında bir şansımız yok Buse
da tanıdık gelmedi mi İnternet o
noktadan bu noktaya gelebildi ise
bankacılık sisteminde de gelişmek için
bir potansiyel olamaz mı
Bu ikinci el ve araba aldığınızı düşünün
50 bin kilometrede bir araba bu şimdiki
koşullar geliyor bu arabayı almak için
bir bebeğinizi falan satmamız
gerekebilir tabi ama
bu arabanın gerçekten 50 bin kilometrede
olduğundan nasıl Emin olabilir siniz ki
bu arabanın önceki sahibi arabayı bir
servise falan götürdü ise kilometresi
kayıtlı olacaktır Ama bu durumda da
servisi yapan firmaya güvenmek zorunda
olduğunuz anlamına gelmez mi bu
Bu güven bugün Güven hakkında
konuşacağım Şu anda ben bu konuşmamı
yaparken dünyadaki Güven gereksinimi
yavaş yavaş ortadan kalkıyor yeni bir
internet çağına girdik ve 3 denen bu
internetin yeni sürümü sayesinde artık
herşey Kesin ve değiştirilemez olacak
artık bir işlem yapmak için kimseye
güvenmek zorunda kalmayacağız her şey
Merkezi olmayan bir sisteme doğru
gidiyor
bu resmi görüyor musunuz bu gerçek
hayatta var olan bir çizim değil bu
sadece bilgisayardaki bir resim dosyası
ve Bunun değeri neredeyse 70 milyon
dolar
bir genellikle dijital Çizim ya da
bilgisayar tarafından oluşturulan bu
resimlere de en eski deniyor bir dijital
içeriğinde 70 milyon dolar gibi bir
fiyata satılabilmesi nin tek sebebi ve 3
en başta saçma bir fikirmiş gibi gelen
enerjilerinde Aslında bu Merkezi olmayan
sisteme geçişte çok büyük bir faydası
oldu Şimdi internette dijital
içeriklerin satışı yap satışı yapılması
zordu Çünkü bir içerik kopyalamayı
tekrar dağıtılabilir ve orijinal hangisi
olduğu tespit edilemez dim ve bu çile
dijital içeriklerin Merkezi olmayan bir
şekilde alınıp satılabilmesi
popülerleşmesi ve bir içeriğinde tüm
geçmişi blok zincirde kaydedileceği ve
değiştiremeyeceği içinde
taklit edilemez oldu
O Elif de ismi de zaten buradan geliyor
açılımından falcı bu token yani
benzersiz demek ilk elektrik
projelerinde bu kadar yüksek fiyatlara
ulaşabilmesi sebebi bu teknoloji halkı
açan ilk projeler olmaları Ha bir de
tabii para atlamak isteyenler için falan
bir araç istediğinde kullanılmadığını
söyle söylesem yalan olur şimdi işte bu
popülerleşme sayesinde de güç kullanımı
çok hızlı bir şekilde artmaya başladı
günümüzde Bitcoin kelimesini duymayan
yoktur hepimiz ne olduğunu biliyoruz
sanal bir para birimi belki Dilek'le
derin Ağla falan bir bağlantısı olduğunu
düşünüyorsunuz dur Ama Bitcoin son
yıllarda bu kadar popülerleşmesi ne
rağmen nasıl çalıştığını bilen çok az
insan tanıyorum Birkaç yıl önce Kripto
paralarla ilgilenmeye başladığımda ailem
bu konuya dolandırıcılık derken saçma
sapan şeylere yatırım yapacağım düşünüp
kızardı Ben Kripto al sakla değil
yazılımlarıyla uğraşıyorum cümlesini o
bu kurmuşum Dur onları karşı ama şimdi
kendileri bile cep telefonundan iki
tuşla kırık doğal saat yapıyor
peki Nasıl çalışıyor Bu kriptolar
anladık Evet Bitcoin kimse yönetmeliği
için güven gereksinimini ortadan
kaldırıyor Ama kimsenin yönetmeliği bir
sistem nasıl çalışabilir kim icep
telefonundan bir kriptopara aldığımızda
nereden geliyor nereye gidiyor with
koyuna sahip olmak ne demek
ki diyelim ki dünyanın en kalitesi yani
Deniz sisteme kayıt olmak istiyorsunuz
liseye kayıt olurken girdiğiniz şifre
hiçbir zaman bir yere kaydedilmez çünkü
Eğer böyle olsaydı şifrelerinizi eklenme
lere karşı çok korumasız olurdu
öyle bir yazılım düşünün ki bu yazılma
bir şifre girdiğinizde çıkan sonuç her
zaman aynı olsun ama bu sonuçtan
şifreniz asla geri elde edilemez aynı
bir demir eritme kalıbı gibi eğer
şifreniz bu kalıp olsaydı çıkan sonuç bu
için her zaman aynı olurdu ama demirin
eritilmeden önce nasıl gözüktüğünü
tahmin edemezsiniz İşte bu teknoloji
kriptoloji demekti ve Kripto paralardaki
Kripto kelimesini Aslında buradan
geliyor bu yazılımlar her yerde
İnternette nerede ulaşırsanız dolaşım
7/24 güvenliğinizi sağlamakta Bunlardan
en popüler şae 256 adlar ve ritmi aynı
zamanda bitcoin'de kullanıyor bunu bu
fonksiyon amacı sonucu olabildiğince
rastgele gözükmesin Ama beni yanlış
anlamayın sonuç kesinlikle askerle değil
ben buraya çevrem 1994 yazdım sürece
sonuç her zaman aynı çıkacak ama
Kerim'in keyfini büyükten küçüğe
çevirmek gibi yaptım küçük bir
değişiklikle sonucun arada bağlantı
kurulamayacak kadar çok değişmesine
sebep olacaktır
bir ve eğer ben Sağdaki sonucu verirsem
ve bunu ne girerek yap oluşturduğu mu
tahmin etmenizi İstersen bunu bulmanız
imkansız olacaktır
Evet fonks bu fırtına almayarak tersine
çevremiz mümkün olmaz mı diyebilirsiniz
ama bunu şimdiye kadar yapabilen olmadı
bu yüzden şimdi internetin çok büyük bir
güvenlik sistemi bu kriptolojik
algoritmaları dayanıyor bu internette
ilgili olanlar araştırabilir bu konuda
neden geri çevrilmediği konusunda çok
güzel matematiksel açıklamalar mevcut
ki
bitcoin'de kriptolojinin mantığını
zekice kullanarak hiçbir bankaya da
devlet etkileşimi gerektirmeden çalışan
dijital bir sistem
Bitcoin Merkezi olmayan internet
konseptini hayata geçirebilen ilk proje
20 kişilik bir sınıf hayal edin Bu
sınıfta herkes birbirinden sıkça borç
alıyor herkesin birbirine sürekli nakit
olarak para alıp vermesi yerine olan
borçlarını bir deftere yazması ve ayın
sonunda hesaplaşması daha mantıklı
olacaktır
bırak ama buradaki problemde elinde
deftere bulunduran kişi herkesin
güveniyor olması gerekmektedir
bankalardaki problem de bu değil midir
Aslında Ayrıca karşı tarafın haberi
olmadan yazılabilecek sahte borçlar da
ortaya çıkabilir bu yüzden bir kişinin
kendisine karşı yazılan borçları
onaylaması gerekmektedir
bu
dijital bir imza düşünün gerçek imzalar
gibi bir kişinin bir şey görüp
onayladığını kanıtlayan taklit edilemez
ve eşi benzeri olmayan bir şey olmadı
ama dijital bir imza nasıl taklit
edilemez olabilir ki diyebilirsiniz imza
oluşturan bir iyi kopyalayıp yapıştırmak
çok kolay olmaz mı ama Tam aksine
dijital imzalar gerçeklerinden çok daha
güvendim ve Detaylara girmeden anlatacak
olursam birçok kriptopara 1 ve 0 lardan
oluşan iki tane anahtar oluşturuyor bir
tanesi herkese açık ve bir tanesi gizlim
kriptoloji fonksiyonlarında bahsetmiştim
giriş yaptığımız şeyin ne olduğunu
tahmin etmemiz mümkün değildi bu sayede
gizli anahtarınızı her zaman sizin
bildiğinizi Ama bu fonksiyonlarda
kullanarak bir şeyler onaylanana
bileceğini kanıtlamış oluyor Yani asla
bir işlem onayladığınız da bunu sadece
sizin yapabileceğinizden gerçekten emin
olabilirsiniz
bazen Benimki sınıftan güneye 12'ye
kadar borç almaktan bu duruma en
mantıklı çözüm herkesin bu deftere bir
miktar para yatırması ve bu paradan daha
fazla harcaması olacaktır buna Double
spending yani tekrarlı harcamayı önlemek
denmektedir ancak gerçek bir defter
ortaya konulan nakit fiziki paranın
varlığını gerektirmektedir buna buna bir
çözüm olarak ise gerçek bir parayla
takas edebileceğiniz Sana biri
uydurmaktır
bir noktaya kadar anlamış olmanız gerek
ki Kripto paralara asla Sadece işlem
geçmişlerinin tutulduğu bir defterden
ibaret
Peki bu defter nerede bulunuyor herkesin
işlemleri onaylaması için elinde bu
defteri bulunduran bir kişiye
güvenmesini gerekiyor konuşmanın
başından beri sorduğum soruya geldik
Eğer şu an herkes de bu defterin bir
kopyası olsaydı ve yapılan işlemler
herkese duyurulur olsaydı herkes bunları
yazsaydı Merkezi olmayan bir sisteminin
temelleri atılmış ol bu
İnsanların oluşturduğu bir Aa şimdi
Ali'nin Ahmet'ten on Konya aldığını
düşünelim Ali Bu işlem herkese
duyulduktan Sonra bu koyunların nerede
isterse istesin harcaya bileğinden nasıl
Emin olabilir yani şimdi hepiniz de bu
defterden var Ama Ahmet'in bu işlemini
yazmamış olabilirsiniz ya da bilerek
yazmamış da olabilirsiniz
Bitcoin bu duruma çözümü en çok işlem
gücü harcanmış deftere inanmaktır
bir profesör Yani iş County kelimesini
belki duymuşsunuzdur bu Bitcoin dahil
olmak üzere birçok Kripto paranın bir
kişinin ne kadar işlem gücüne sahip
olduğunu belirlemek için kullandığı bir
yöntem şimdiye kadar yazılmış olan tüm
işlemlerin olduğu defteri alıp sonra bir
sayı eklediğiniz ifade edildi bizim Az
önce bahsettiğim kriptoloji
algoritmalarında birinden geçirdiğinizi
milk 30 bitin sıfır çıkma ihtimali
kaçtır şimdi diyelim 250 denedi ve ilik
olmadı 300 denedik geçirdik olmadı bu
sayı tutana kadar milyarlarca işlem
yapmak dışında bir şansımız olmayacaktır
ve hatta bu deftere bir tane daha işlem
bile eklenirse bütün bu milyarlarca
işlemi bir daha yapmamız gerekecektir
bir ve bir defteri bloklar ayırarak
düzenleyebiliriz her blokta belirli
sayıda yapılan işlem ve az önce
bahsettiğim bulduğumuz bir iş Kanıt
sayısı bulunuyor aynı zamanda her blokta
bir önceki bloğunda işkın sayısı
bulunmakta
Bu yüz böylece bir tane geçmişte
yapılmış işlemi değiştirmek isteseydiniz
o bloğun iş Kanıt sayısı değiştirdi Bu
da sonraki blog tepesindeki değiştirdi E
bu da kriptoloji fonksiyona girdiğinde
oglan sonucunu etkileyeceği için o
bloğunda yıkıntı sayısı değişmesi
gerekirdi Yani eğer bir işlemi
değiştirseydi niz tüm bloklar bozulurdu
ve tüm çıkıntısı ve tekrar hesaplanması
gerekirdi işte blokların birbiriyle bu
şekilde bağlantılı olmasına blok çay
indiriyor blokzincir deniyor İşte bu
sayede kayıplar asla değiştirilemiyor
Herkes bu noktada bir blog oluşturabilir
tek yapması gereken işlemleri dinlemek
yazmak ve bir sıkıntı sayısı bulana
kadar denemek ve bunu bulunca da herkese
duyurmak
Evet şimdi siz bir blok oluşturduğunuzda
harcadığınız işlem gücü için Çünkü
elektrik harcıyorsunuz Sonuçta belli bir
miktarda koyun ödüllendirilir siniz buna
blok ödülü denmektedir ve Aslında bu da
bit koyunların nereden geldiğini
cevabıdır Madencilik d-blokları
onaylayarak Aslında ekonomiye yeni
koyunlara katmaktır anlamı budur
madenciliğinin Eğer sahte Bir işlemin
duyurulmasından dolayı iki farklı zincir
oluşursa her zaman en çok işlem gücü
harcanmış zinciri inanıl acağı için bu
işle bu sistem hiç ve güven
gerektirmekte tamamen işlem gücüne
dayanmakta da eğer aranızdan birisi beni
sahte bir işlemle kandırmak isteseydim
mesela aranızdan biri bana 100 koyun
göndersem Ama bunu sadece bana söylesen
aranızda defter tutan kimseye söylemesem
o kişinin o kişinin hala 100k ne
olduğunu düşünürdünüz hepiniz ama bana
göre ben o yüz koyunu aldım ve belki
karşılığında bir şey verdim o kişinin bu
dolandırıcılığı sürdürebilmesi için
herkesten önce bir iş Kanıt sayısı
bulması gerekirdi
Bu yüzden dünyadaki tüm işlem gücünün
yüzde 50'den fazla sahip olması
gerekirdi Buna da zaten yüzde 51
saldırısı denmektedir bir ancak Bitcoin
popülerliği ve kullanıcı sayısının
fazlalığından dolayı böyle bir saldırı
mümkün olmayacaktır ancak tabi
madencilerin birleşip işlem gücünü
birleştirip blok ödülü bölüşmesi gibi
olaylarda olmaktadır bunlara havuz
denmektedir Bu topluluklara bu 151
saldırısına birazcık da olsa daha mümkün
kılmaktadır ama bu çok ayrı bir konu
olduğu için şimdi girmiyorum
çok az önce bahsettiğim kriptoloji
algoritmasında bulunması gereken
sıfırların sayısına da blok zorluğu
dönmekte blok zoru ne kadar fazla olursa
bu iş kanıtını domuz için harcamanız
gereken işlem gücü de o kadar fazla
olacaktır
bitcoin'de her bloğun onaylama süresi
yaklaşık 10 dakika olacak şekilde blok
zorluğunu ayarlayarak gelişen teknoloji
ve Kişi sayısına rağmen ağız Tabi bir
şekilde ilerlemesini sağlamaktadır
bir Ve tabii ki bu kadar işlem için
dünyada yapılan harcanan enerjinin
dünyaya olan zararları tartışılmaktadır
Bitcoin ve diğer Kripto paralar herhangi
bir bankadan Herhangi bir banka
sisteminden çok daha fazla enerji
harcamaktadır ancak ilerleyen
teknolojiler ile birçok alternatif
sunulmuştur ve Eter gibi çok büyük
koyunlar de bu alternatiflere yavaş
yavaş adapte olmaktadır
bu Kripto paralar da sıkça şikayet bu
konu ise yüksek işlem ücretleri Bitcoin
her 210.000 blokta bir yani Yaklaşık
dört yılda bir bahsettiğim blok ödülünü
yarıya indiriyor yani asla 21 milyondan
fazla bitki olmayacak bak Ancak bu
maymunların ileride para kazanamayacağı
anlamına gelmiyor Çünkü aynı zamanda Biz
yaptığımız işlemlerin yanında küçük bir
miktarda Madenciler epay bırakabiliyor
Uz Bunu neden mi yapıyoruz Çünkü Bitcoin
sınırlara geriye bir blog da en fazla
iki 1400 civarı işlem bulunabiliyor ve
Madenciler yapılan her işlemi biblo
dahil edemeyeceği için en yüksek işlem
ücreti ödeyenler öncelik veriyor Yo
zamanlarda da işlem ücretlerini
artmasının sebebi bu Aslında
başta verdiğim araba örneğine dönecek
olursak bir arabanın kilometresi bir
evin tadilat geçmişi gibi
değiştirilmesini istemediğiniz şeyler E1
blok zincirde depolayabilir siniz bu
Ancak sıfırdan bir blog şeyi yapmak hem
masraflı olabilir hem çok zaman harca
tabidir hem de güvenlik problemler
ortaya çıkarabilir Bu yüzden Eter gibi
halihazırda bulunan bir blok şeyinde
yazılımınızı yazmak isteyebilirsiniz
işte blok Şener'le birlikte çalışan bu
yazılımları akıllı Anlaşma denmekte ve
Bu akıllı anlaşmaların gelişmesiyle de
Aslı çok sıkça duyduğumuz bir kelime
ortaya çıktı tokenler sana size tokenler
koyunlarla aynı şey değil tokenler
akıllı anlaşmalarla yönetilen koyun gibi
davranan yazılımlar bu koyun gibi
davranan yazılımları yazmak o kadar
kolaylaştı ki ethereum blok seninde bile
30 binden fazla Tok en bulunuyor Ve
sürekli de bunların sayısı artıyor
binlerce farklı proje ve binlerce farklı
teknolojiyle Ama şunu da söylemeden
geçemeyeceğim bu tokenler e
dolandırıcılık için kullanan insanların
sayısı da çok fazla yani dikkatli
olmakta fayda var yeni proje Ya aslında
işte bu tokenler de aslında halkın
Kripto dünyasına dahil olmasında çok
büyük bir etkisi olmuştur
halk neden sağlık bu dünyadan kaçmaya
çalışıyorsun o zamanlardan matriksin
gerçek olmak istiyor olmaya başladı bir
Çağa girdik gibi oldu
artık bu dünyadan kaç açabileceğiniz
isminizi değiştirebileceğiniz görüşünüzü
değiştirebileceğiniz para
kazanabileceğiniz ve hatta bu parayı
Kumarda da kaybedebileceğini dünyalar
var
metaphors üç boyutlu gözlüklerinizi
takıp gidebileceğiniz bu dünyalar blok
çimenlerde yönetiliyor arsalar blok
Şener alır satılıyor sahip olduğu şeyler
blok Şener'le korunuyor aynı zamanda
yerel koyun birimleriyle birçok şey
yapılabiliyor
2011 yılında çıkan ready-player-one
isimli filmde asla Ta o zamandan Bu
konsepte çok iyi almış bir film the
milyon dolar Home PC adlı projede belki
duymuşsunuzdur Alex Sivaslı bir öğrenci
üniversite masraflarını ödeyebilmek bu
para toplama Adına Bir web site yapıyor
bu nefse 1 milyon pikselden oluşuyor ve
her piksele bir dolardan satışa sunuyor
bu pistleri alanlar istediği şey
koyabilir bitsin içine bu pikselleri
reklam yapmak amaçlı veya yatırım amaçlı
alan insanların parası boşa gidiyor ama
Alex'i projede başarılı oluyor ve 1
milyon dolar toplamayı başarıyor
Ben meteorolojide Aslında biraz bu
projeye benzetiyorum yani
Meteoroloji'den alınan arsaların
değerini koruyacak konusunda biraz
şüpheliyim ama bence sizi düşündürmeye
Jack kadar paralarla blok şeyleri
keşfetmeniz Kripto paralarla
ilgilenmeniz yazılımlarıyla uğraşmanız
veya metal ölürse dahil olmanız da bir
sakınca yok
benim konuşmam bu kadardı Umarım sizlere
Bu konuda bir şeyler kata bilmişimdir
bir
[Alkış]
bu paraları ilginizi çekebilir Sen ne
mutlu bana
[Alkış]